last year we were here just three days
after the incident where the shark came
up got very aggressive we were crawling
out on the rocks as fast as we can and
it was crazy these men are on a mission
to hunt down a killer shark I'm gonna
use this spear and this barb will go in
stick in his skin really strong Kurt
it's good for sharks okay be extra safe
the target is this four and a half meter
tiger shark
recognizable by its ragged fin this
shark has a notorious and terrifying
history this animal in particular has
been showing aggressive behavior to
divers there was an attack on a diver
just about a year ago
the diver lost so much blood she later
died of her injuries
get this approach wrong and the predator
could claim another victim
you know your Adrenaline's going and
you're not really thinking about
anything but getting the spear point
right in the right place as the shark
circles now is the moment to strike
[Music]
but these divers aren't killing sharks
they're tagging them it's part of
research being carried out by scientists
like these men and women across the
globe
underlying their work is a huge question
essential to the health of the planet
[Music]
what's the best way to protect the ocean
against the devastation being inflicted
by humanity
[Music]
some 340 miles of the Pacific coast of
Costa Rica sits the island of Coco's
one of the world's most stunning marine
protected areas
all fishing is banned here and the
pristine waters are famous for their
astonishing variety of marine life
but this is no longer the paradise of
ocean life it used to be when you look
at the data I'm only seeing a fraction
of what I would have seen if I had come
here when I was thirty instead of when I
was sixty marine biologist Tod Steiner
is part of a group of scientists who
have discovered the reason for this
sharp decline in marine life many of the
species found inside this protected area
have an inconvenient habit of leaving it
with highly migratory species they don't
stay in one place so as they migrate
between their feeding areas and their
nesting areas we need to protect these
entire swim ways along these unprotected
swim ways migratory species are being
caught and killed
I am really really stoked to go to
koco's Todd and his colleague Kevin
Wayne are trying to persuade the Costa
Rican government to expand the small
marine protected area around Koko's
Island
and there are huge gaps of ocean in
which these animals are swimming but in
which there is no protection for them
so one of the things that we're trying
to discover is where their migratory
pathways are and where their important
habitats are
by gathering data about these migration
routes the scientists are building a
case for enlarging the no fishing zone
is critical for designing and managing
marine protected areas the more animals
that we know about the better we can
design and manage these areas guys ready
today the team are on the trail of the
animals at the heart of the oceans
ecosystem sharks so it's really
important to protect sharks because
they're the top predators of the ocean
they control the entire food chain and
if you kill the top predators you have a
cascading effect that diminishes all the
life in the oceans so it's not just
about protecting sharks it's about
protecting the entire ocean ecosystem
this is one of the places that has
sharks
whether or not we'll catch something who
knows it's fishing right we have four
tags these tags are acoustic tracking
devices they will be able to monitor the
movement of sharks along the swim ways
for years to come and someone else has
to write then pre caudal fork and total
but there's just one snag the team have
got to catch a shark first they'll need
to find hook and cut the animal open
without hurting it or themselves what
we're gonna do with this tag is we're
actually going to surgically implant it
inside of the body cavity of the animal
to lure the shark in fresh bait is
attached to the hook
over the past 10 years scientists here
have tracked more than 1,200 animals but
today promises something new
[Music]
for the first time a silver tip shark
could be tagged in these waters but the
shark has other ideas
wait let's let's let him go for a second
so let's listen listen let's try and do
this the other way
I've just made an incision and I've put
in the acoustic tag and we're just
stitching this animal and after we've
sutured the animal up and it has this
tag inside of it we release that shark
to go about his merry way
all the while sending out this special
code impulsive sound and every time that
transmission is received we will know
where that shark is hold the hook just
right there okay
thank you for remembering to take off
this I forgot yeah so that was really
good we tagged a silver tip shark first
time that species has been tagged you
know we're starting to have the
beginnings of a study for this species
but that's really really important
[Music]
the scientists have already discovered
that at least three endangered species
of shark and two species of endangered
turtle migrate along a vast underwater
highway
it stretches from the protected area
around Koko's Island to the protected
waters around the Galapagos Islands over
400 miles away
[Music]
so we need to expand the marine
protected areas and now connect these
these hotspots we've now identified an
area in between these where these
animals are swimming back and forth a
superhighway Todd hopes the turning most
if not all of this giant swim way into a
no fishing zone will be a blueprint that
is copied across the world but he and
his fellow scientists have got their
work cut out over the past 20 years
they've recorded declining shark
populations as much as 90% in one
species around Cocos Island
it's part of a wider global trend that
sees an estimated a hundred million
sharks killed each year mainly because
of high demand for shark fins in Asia so
Punta Arenas is the main fishing port of
Costa Rica and this is also the heart of
the shark finning industry Randle arose
is the man determined to turn scientific
research into practical change here he's
devoted his life to lobbying the Costa
Rican government to protect the swimway
between kokis Island and the Galapagos
Islands and he wants shark fishing to be
outlawed so look they're landing some
sharks right here and how lucky that's
all sharks right there
now those are all silky sharks but from
what I can tell this is an endangered
species although Randall's campaigning
has brought some regulation of shark
finning it's still legal to catch and
land sharks in Costa Rica all right
[Music]
constant legal battles with the
government and fishing Lobby have made
him a public enemy for many here this is
a cat-and-mouse game as soon as we have
a policy change we have the fisherman in
the Costa Rican Fisheries Department
finding a loophole or contending what
we're doing you know so we closed the
door they come in through the back door
we close it back door they come in
through the kitchen so yeah our
victories never last very long they
recognize me
hey they got sharks look at that shark
tails
they're showing a shark tails look shark
bodies yeah there you go look look
how's her kimono says there kimonos I
told you they recognized me easy
he said round we'll come over here and
we'll put the shark tail up your ass I'm
hated by the fishermen I'm not working
to put long liners or fishermen out of
business
I'm working to stop the shark fin trade
and I'm working towards sustainable
fishing randall is adamant the fishing
lobbies influence is the main reason the
swim way between Cocos Island and the
Galapagos Islands remains unprotected
and every time there's an effort to
expand the protected area the fishermen
of Punta Arenas they always say no
they're very powerful economically and
politically and so far they've been very
effective
but many fishermen here don't buy the
lime that the Costa Rican government is
in their pocket pero también tenemos
contendere coke a Costa Rica le mini la
pesca no see a camel affect us you see a
leper material FLOTUS Internacional is
occurring at best King and mr. O'Mara's
fishermen here point the finger their
government for granting licenses to
foreign fishing vessels they say one of
these boats can catch more in two months
than the entire Costa Rican long line of
Li do in a year no podemos company
Kahuna's DeMarcus yonas Amen cemento
grandes en el cual su equipo de Sunol
red de casi todos que lo metro de Largo
Porto siento Metro de fondo ear echo
hello Calle entropay pueden ser
cincuenta Sesenta siento Nellas au solo
circle
throw in the fishing lobbies mistrust of
conservationists and it's easy to see
why they are so opposed to protecting
the swimway between Cocos Island and the
Galapagos Islands porque protección de
decir no pace-car conservación con
nombre no llegamos a tener puer nas
términos Loompas Cadore a pasado EK
black tea das cacao a en su a lo que
como sector estamos haciendo there's
another obstacle to making the swim way
a protected area its size
the task of policing the no-fishing zone
around Cocos Island currently Falls to a
team of 19 Rangers but with no powers of
arrest all this squad can really seize
on nets in Estes mas o menos diez años
más o menos que tenemos de Soraka don
dole a garel ok la pesca legal hemos
encontrado y tenemos parte SE material
akka a confess cow the ranges are
already underpowered their 3.4 million
dollar radar system has been broken for
months no solamente natal brother
general equipo de el arma en la
capacidad jihad intercepted it tambien
tener una communication Clara de camões
vamonos a
organizaciones then throw and go yellow
right now there's a 12-mile no-fishing
zone to enforce around cocos island but
protecting the swim way would mean
policing tens of thousands of square
miles of water in which case they're
going to need a bigger boat
[Music]
any attempt to conserve areas of the
ocean properly brings a host of
challenges not least when it comes to
protecting the ocean from its greatest
threat climate change this is forcing a
major rethink about how marine protected
areas should be designed and selected in
the future dr. Greg stone is one of the
leading scientists in this field and
he's taking a team to one of the most
remote corners of the globe as part of
his latest research it really is one of
the last places that
[Music]
it's hard to get to
beautiful
Oh captain
this is Canton Lagoon we are in the
heart of the Pacific Ocean to get here
we had to fly to the furthest commercial
destination that I'm aware of in the
Pacific and then from there we chartered
a plane to take us another four or five
hundred miles to here Canton island our
closest human neighbors well therap in
the Space Station Canton Island is part
of the nation of Carabas right in the
middle of the Pacific two thousand miles
from Hawaii it's at the center of the
Phoenix islands protected area the size
of California this is one of the largest
marine conservation parks in the world
renowned for its rich variety of marine
life and now we are surrounded by coral
reefs were surrounded by vast tuna herds
were surrounded by whales and dolphins
all right you guys have masks and weight
belts it's all about air Greg helped set
up this marine protected area with the
Kyra Bass government Bom Bom Bom Bom so
spartacus faster
he and his team have traveled all the
way out here because it is one of the
best places on earth to investigate the
effects of climate change on the ocean
you know there are so many threats that
the ocean faces from humanity
overfishing pollution and climate change
but here in the Phoenix islands
protected area we are so far from all
the other threats from humanity that all
the reef is experiencing is climate
change which makes it such a great
laboratory for understanding this and
this is a critical moment according to
the latest satellite data an El Nino may
be forming a natural event which
temporarily warms local water
temperatures providing a glimpse into
the future effects of climate change for
the region who's a nice piece of coral
right here I like that
kind of shallow yeah let's we'll go in
around here
the scientists plan to record how the
coral reefs here cope with a spike in
temperature
they hope to find out how resilient
these reefs might be to warming waters
the destruction of coral reefs as a
result of climate change is disastrous
for the oceans ecosystem so this is
high-stakes research let's get suited up
guys yeah this looks pretty good I guess
we'll probably drop in right at the bow
it looks to me like the coral is in
pretty good shape now so we're in a good
moment to get these instruments in the
water the plan is to install around ten
thermometers on the lagoon floor what we
got here is a long-term under water
temperature recorder this will record
the seat temperature every 30 seconds
for the next year or two and we're gonna
fasten it to the reef and these are
buoys to help us find it a year or two
from now and this will enable us to
understand the temperature changes
you get into the water and you feel the
energy the the photosynthesis the
production of these the easy corals then
you look at them they're so vibrant it's
clear enough those you can see
everything it's just like wow the ocean
is alive it's really a magical place
how was it great corals in good shape
find a nice spot for the lager I'm happy
with that I didn't see any grain or
anything going wrong yet so that's a
good sign I was afraid we'd see some
bleaching already coral bleaching is one
of the major kinds of damage inflicted
by climate change but previous research
has suggested that the coral here has a
rare ability to survive we've witnessed
two major bleaching events that come
through here and when it first happened
about 17 years ago we were also
depressed because we thought that was
the end of this spectacular system just
very depressing dead brown black broken
coral and we we almost needed Prozac try
to cheer ourselves up it was so bad but
then it bounced back with incredible
vigor it was almost like finding someone
who was almost dead get up and walk the
next week never had we seen a reef
system respond like that with another
temperature hike potentially brewing
greg is hoping this latest research will
provide more evidence to suggest that
this coral is equipped to resist climate
change
one of the Holy Grails and climate and
ocean coral researches is finding coral
animals and and other reef organisms
that can withstand the heating that's
happening now in the planet but it looks
like Nature might have done it for us
here in the Phoenix islands and it could
be that this has applications throughout
the world it's not an understatement to
say that perhaps the progenitors of
future reefs in the world could lie here
they could actually become corals that
could be moved elsewhere Greg believes
scientists should weigh the effort
required to set up a marine protected
area against its potential benefits
which is why he would prioritize areas
like this one with resilient corals
picture is pretty dismal for
rank-and-file coral reefs around the
planet and it's the ones that can
withstand this heating that can
withstand these fluxes in the climate
that we're looking for and we've got to
make tough choices now we've got to pick
those places that are going to have the
biggest impact into the future
[Music]
the worldwide search for those places
and for the most effective way to use
them is leading to some unlikely
destinations in the rather less tropical
waters of West Wales the question is
being asked can marine protected areas
be designed not only to survive climate
change but also to help fight it marine
scientist dr. Richard Unsworth is hoping
to prove the answer is yes so this is
incredibly simple all these are small in
these protected waters he is planting
one of the oceans less glamorous
organisms seagrass
[Music]
what we're trying to achieve here is
quick really simple way of restoring see
dress really low tech equipment global
stocks of seagrass have declined by
nearly 30 percent since 1980 richard
argues that wide-scale restoration of
seagrass could help in the battle
against climate change have been lost
all around 12:00 at the powerhouse of
the ocean people refer to as the lungs
of the sea and we really must bring
these habitats back because they store
carbon 30 times faster than rainforests
and therefore there's one part of the
solution to climate change I have young
children I can't I can't look them in
the eye and know that I'm not doing
something against the private chain
reducing carbon emissions is the most
important weapon in the fight against
climate change
but progress has been slow and Richards
work with seagrass is just one of
several novel solutions scientists are
exploring to save the ocean from global
warming
marine-protected areas currently make up
only 3.6 percent of the ocean it's
science
that will drive efforts to add to and
expand those areas to select them to
conserve the rich and diverse life
within them and to adapt them to deal
with the specific and urgent challenges
each faces think of the ocean as a very
sick relative going into your relatives
bedroom and tucking them in and giving
them a hot cup of tea it'll help but the
situation is so serious you need to hire
a doctor and we need the best science
and we need the best mind couldn't be
more urgent and it couldn't be a better
time for everyone to step forward